According to a civil rights organization,
between 2008 and 2019, the
Department of Education received a
187 percent increase in the
number of complaints of discrimination and
other types of attacks at charter schools.
bir zet
camps su 11th human rights organization
says hispanic and asian students have
been the victims of such discrimination
in recent years
the department of education office for civil rights is
the agency responsible for investigating
all types of discrimination in
schools  and also to ensure that cases
of assault or sexual harassment in schools
and universities are properly
investigated. According
to civil rights organizations, the problem is
that this office has not received
sufficient increases in its
budget to be able to adequately
respond to the increase in the number of
complaints.  that's why 80
civil rights organizations
a letter to me  Members of Congress to
request that the budget for the Office
of Civil Rights be increased
by 100 percent to $260
million for the next fiscal year,
but for now President Byron
has only requested a 10% increase in
the budget for  the office for
civil rights reinforcing in washington
alexandra lemon